[Musique]
le 26 mai toutes les françaises et tous
les français vont pouvoir avec leurs
bulletins de vote s'exprimer et je pense
que ce bulletin de vote il doit servir à
au moins deux choses d'abord sanctionné
emmanuel macron c'est le premier scrutin
depuis les élections présidentielles de
nous avons un président qui a mené une
politique antisociale anti écologique il
faut être capable de le sanctionner dans
les urnes mais aussi plus loin que ça le
26 mai c'est l'occasion de réorienter la
politique européenne
nous avons besoin de coopération à
l'échelle de l'europe notamment pour
répondre à l'urgence climatique et c'est
ce que les députés de la france en sont
mises à l'avant faire c'est une
politique d'abord qui se donne les
moyens de sortir des traités dans le
temps les traités européens
comme ils sont prêts aujourd'hui ils
organisent la concurrence sociale et la
concurrence fiscale
c'est la course au dumping social et
fiscal est donc évidemment ça creuse les
inégalités ça dégrade les conditions de
vie de tout le monde il faut d'autres
règles du jeu au niveau européen est la
condition pour ça c'est la mort de
sortir les traiter
[Musique]
il faut préserver nos services publics
notamment ceux de transports et de
l'énergie
si nous voulons faire une transition
écologique nous avons besoin d'organiser
un transport bas carbone ça veut dire
compter notamment sur le ferroviaire
alors même que en ce moment la
commission européenne et le président de
la république ouvre à la concurrence
privatise à tour de bras les puis plus
généralement à une proposition que nous
faisons à la france un saut mise à
l'échelle européenne
elle se serait de mettre en place ce
qu'on appelle une règle verte terre
plutôt que la règle absurde de refuser
les déficits publics
nous nous proposons une règle d'intérêt
général qui est de ne pas prélever dans
l'écosystème plus que ce qu'il a la
capacité de renouveler c'est ce qu'on
appelle la règle verte et c'est ce que
nous défendons à la france insoumise
[Musique]